[Music]
thank you
what kind of person is shamima begum the
Isis bride who recently lost her appeal
to return to the UK has divided public
opinion over the past few years Andrew
jury is into extreme tourism and has
visited some of the most dangerous parts
of the world just how dangerous does he
think begum is Andrew joins me now
Andy thanks for joining spectator TV
you've written for the magazine this
week about the friendship you say that
you've built up with shamima begum how
did this come about I think friendship
was uh past tense now because my latest
stuff was probably upset her quite a bit
um it come about I was filming a
documentary called danger zone which
followed me in My Strange Life of
holidays and danger zones so as a day
off from filming we were close to the
Rose Camp which means kept
and I thought because there was a lot of
journalists have been thrown out so she
said no to everybody so I thought it was
a bit of a challenge so I wanted to go
and see her and no it was a good story
the production company weren't
interested in her at all so went into
the camp but you personally wanted to
meet her yeah of course she's a big
story at home
um I can remember the pictures of seeing
her come through the airport with her
other two friends and yeah of course it
was a big story so I went into the camp
expecting to get told to go away but um
I had a pre-plan
um I was in a Netflix documentary where
I was in an orphanage and it was quite a
tear-jerking scene so I thought it might
be a good idea to show that and show my
softer side
um I showed but I showed her it she
kind of got brought into it I think she
could realize I wasn't on his Hardline
newspaper journalists so she saw me as
somebody was a bit different than she'd
had seen before and she accepted me
um and the interview which I had with
her wasn't the Gen about the heads and
the bins the suicide vest it was
generally about her about you know what
she used to do in her life when she was
younger what was her interest and she
bought into it and then she liked me
and as I the bit I still regret now as I
went to leave us a kind of shake your
hands I didn't want to offend her
because she was a Muslim off in my hand
she said I can have a hug
um she gave me a hug and she started to
cry I'd never seen emotion before I
don't know now whether that was
orchestrated by herself as it went along
but that made some sort of bond I got a
daughter her age so I didn't see her at
that point as a Terrace I saw as a
victim
um in my mind she was groomed and at
that point and kind of that was about it
I never expected to ever see her again
and I left but how wrong I was I want to
go into that full story but first I
think a lot of viewers will be wondering
what exactly an extreme holiday is
because this was certainly not the first
or last time you went on one what does
that entail
Intel's being pretty stupid and going
places where everybody advises you not
to go the government advised not to go
though I generally went there right so
it's taken me from to chechnya it's
taken me Ku Klux Klan
um Frontline battle
um in kirkuk I've been taken hostage
only for a day and they bought me a
kebab well that makes it okay and then
rescuing a bear recently in war-torn
Ukraine so that's not your general
holiday and are you an adrenaline junkie
is that what you're seeking
it wasn't it was until the media took
over yeah I liked the adrenaline like
the buzz and I also like to tell
people's story when you come back I
always enjoyed relaying somebody's story
right through myself then I had the
medium of newspapers to do that and I
enjoyed I just enjoy that
um well uh this extreme holiday took you
to shimima and you visited her many
times at the refugee camp afterwards
what is it like in this prison camp what
are the conditions like
compared to a refugee camp which I've
been through in raqqa before
it's not bad I don't think it's it's a
Concrete in the middle of a concrete
bases with tents with kind of un plastic
sheeting made into a tent form shamim
has got a TV in a room she's got a fan
of air conditioning I don't know where
she's getting the money but and she has
and she's quite well dressed but it's a
Dusty dirty Place they've got a shopping
area where they can go and buy our
clothes and baby because a lot of
children in there as well as the baby
food Foods so they have money they I
don't know how they earn it because she
never told me at the prison camp it's
split into two so you've got the real
extreme upper top end of the camp which
they don't think they could be
deregulized they're up there because
they're and they don't really mix with
the more Western girls
um which are on the other side which is
supposed to be a little bit easier
and you said at the start of our
interview that you think you were wrong
in terms of your first impression of
shamima what changed during your visit
um well on my second visit
um she told I knew that she could have a
phone call home she was entitled to one
phone call one week
um and I thought that'd be from the
office there's an Administration office
in there but she said they got mobile
phones in the camp so I gave her my
mobile number expecting a phone call but
I got text messages regular and one of
those text messages changed everything
about her I mean I had a brother died of
cancer young so I always kept that with
me and it never left me and when I was
there on my second visit in her purse
she has these two pictures and the third
one for charging her children the oldest
child I think was about eight months
when he died a chocolate man's face and
it was like a happy scene of cake making
um and I was quite upset by it because a
child obviously an innocent child had
died and it was eight months old so I
text sent a message to her a text
message and said I was really sad when I
saw that photograph of your your little
one and her response shot me she said oh
don't worry I'm over that part of my
life it doesn't make me sad anymore
and that I still can't understand I'd
say living with death myself of a young
child I just couldn't fathom how she
could be that way and how it seemed so
cold
it seems extremely cold I can't fathom
it either that said we have not grown up
in an Isis Community we haven't had the
experiences she had do you think perhaps
this was her way of deflecting what is
overwhelming and inconsolable pain
people always mention the trauma of what
she went for according to her on a
documentary never went for anybody she
was stuck in a room for seven months
didn't do anything stayed in and had no
trauma it was only during the bombing at
the end when Bagus actually got taken
out by the Western Alliance that she
actually had any trauma according to her
so I know I don't agree with that I
still think he'd hold the emotions I
mean if you were in a traumatic
situation your children got killed I
don't I don't agree with that at all do
you still see her as a victim on any
level
um
trafficking or a victim of grooming I
asked her and she ironically I watched
the documentary again stop trying to
refer back to that but she said that she
had trouble fitting in society she um
racially she shared racing racist abuse
and racially she find difficult
um to fit into a community well she
lived in a Bangladeshi community so that
would have been untrue and the question
about racism she she I asked her about
that and she said she'd only had one
small racist comment when she was in
infant School
was quite shocked so I don't think she
was groomed and then we've seen a video
and that video shown of the the park
everybody knows about the Isis video
propaganda video where you see this
beautiful scene this park and they've
got a Catherine wheel bumper cars and
they're walking around with candy floss
now if that was the one video that she
watched
um to The Grooming video it's not true
I want to talk about the screaming point
a bit more because I think one of the
most startling points of of your article
for The Spectator is you say I spent
with the time you spent with her quote I
also went from thinking that she had
been groomed to thinking she was trying
to groom me yeah how do you understand
the definition of grooming in that
scenario it's a difficult one isn't it
it's changing somebody's beliefs and I
think at all persuasion and I think she
was doing that with me I think
I think she was trying um trying to work
me I suppose I mean her side would be
work by ISIS to um to change her opinion
to say that she was going to go to a
utopic situation
um I suppose grooming was with me was
conditioned me to her belief conditioned
me towards how she was I think critics
however would say that somebody in your
position with a family stability the
ability to travel is not a heart
Contender to be groomed where she
um you know despite the horrible things
that she owns up to doing and you know
needs to be accountable for was
ultimately a child and under UK law
would have been a victim of that lease
rape
um I think that's 15 year olds always
been used so many times it's you could
say that about a child that kills I mean
is everybody innocent at the age of 15 I
don't think so she could still have the
thoughts
um I think she went on her own free will
I don't think she was coaxed another
girl called because most people there
was only three girls at verse four a
girl that went before
um shamina shamina went before and I
think it was just a conversation I I
don't think she did realize how extreme
it would be I would say that for sure
but she still had an anti-british
anti-west feeling do you think perhaps
she saw you as somebody who could help
her get back to the UK and when she
realized that you couldn't or wouldn't
that's when her attitude towards you
changed no her attitude changed toward
me when I wrote a newspaper article in
the paper that she didn't like right so
I wrote an article came back and said
that she could face trial and do 20
years in prison the newspaper article I
won't say the newspaper unless you want
me to stated that she could be hung I
never said that so once again the paper
wrote the article wrong and which I got
them to apologize for and they
apologized to the SDF but however it was
wrong and I said shameem sorry the
article was wrong it wasn't what I wrote
and I sent her the actual transcript of
the right article but she come back and
said it doesn't matter about the article
don't care what article it was it's who
what paper you put it in my response to
Algos well you sold your country out you
worry about where I sold a newspaper
article and that was the last I heard of
her you say in the piece that you quote
never had an agenda when you met shamima
no you did help other journalists with
their interviews to interview me and
other Isis Brides where you paid for the
support that you gave the journalists
received a penny from any work I've done
for shameema at all
but do you were you paid for helping
other journalists get in touch with
other Isis Brides when you were in the
area paid any money at all for anything
I've done within that prison camp do you
think her perception of you might have
also changed when she saw you were
working with other journalists no she
actually liked it I mean the um Good
Morning Britain live interview she apart
from having a tantrum halfway through it
um she seemed to like it now it took
others after that and she liked that it
was simply because I think she had a
documentary made about her and I think
she might be manipulated by that
journalist not to speak to anybody else
shamima has just lost her appeal to
return to the UK what do you make of
that decision have the courts made the
right call
um no I don't
um I don't think you should be if you
were born in this country I don't think
you should be able to take somebody's
citizenship away from them I don't think
you can you're British you're born
British it doesn't matter what
generation of British your parents are
you're born in this country and I don't
think it's right I think she should come
back face trial here for our crimes I
think we have enough evidence or they
have enough evidence and I think that's
what should happen she should come here
and serve prison sentence here
um feeling about her because I know her
so well last time she had a
um an appeal turned down in the high
court she was suicidal you were there at
the time weren't you with her I spoke to
her within hours or within days of that
being turned down she told me how
suicidal she felt and how flat she felt
and as a human being see it's a mixed
emotions because when you actually
I I don't hate her but I just don't like
what she stood for and I don't like the
way that she's gone but however
as a person I don't want someone in the
camp a young girl to be seen worried
about you know or contemplating and
committing suicide because I feel
terribly guilty if I was part of
anything to do with that
does shamima have any more options and
trying to come to the UK she
um her options are well she's got the
core human rights so Elizabeth said
they're going to appeal they can appeal
against the Seattle Court's decision but
ultimately even if she gets a
citizenship some way
back then I would suggest that they'll
probably try her in Syria I don't think
the government are allowed to come here
because you can imagine a government
that repatriates so it'd be a real
uncomfortable situation there's such a
um I think such a
adverse feeling towards shamim I don't
think it would be a good thing for any
government to bring it back so I think
it's a possibility she could go to trial
and Syria for about 20 years
I think she could get that
Andy thanks for joining me
[Music]